all right good evening everybody
welcome to the garden committee 19
October 2017 I could just read out the
emergence of Appalachian space
shouldn't we be required to migrate the
building would you please leave the
building by the nearest available exit
container or assembly part point will be
in the public car park at the side of
the city sweet please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the Belle
vendôme tent given permission to do so
by council staff he's also note that
this meeting is called a recording thank
you
I just feel like I want to stand for the
for that for the next little bit this
you all know we've suddenly lost
counselor black quite certainly he was a
significant feature of the Development
Committee the Planning Committee over a
a serious number of your seems more like
an installation to the to emit II than
anything else he certainly contributed
to many of the things that were talking
about tonight through his membership of
the various planning policy committees
that we have and he has been a really
active part of the Council for many many
years by particularly having had the
privilege of sitting up in this position
for many years always picture him
sitting over there particularly when he
used to do that
when he wanted a little question that
are you always have you would always
have that question but I knew as
chairman that when when Chris black
wanted to say something it wasn't just
because he'd been badgered by members of
the public it wasn't just because he
didn't like something whenever he spoke
he was always relating to a policy or
something in the core strategy
it was very wise words that he was
always he would always speak and I think
that to the council and particularly to
the planning the way in which planning
works of Rochford he will be a
significant loss but more than that I
think I'll just missing from the
committee if members would like to join
me I think it's appropriate if we take
another minute in memory
life
okay
the castle Newports chairman I just
wanted to say a few words myself like I
was very fortunate that Christmas a
friend and a colleague
his absence I'm sure will be felt by
many not justice committee throughout
the council
he was very passionate and knowledgeable
on planning issues watching Chris in
action and several development committee
meetings from the public gallery in the
past provided me with the insights and
some inspiration to become a counselor
when Chris first approached me to join
the Lib Dems I was adamant that I would
not join
party however over time her multiple
cups of coffee later
crystal persuaded me that the Lib Dems
shared common values to with Joan when
Kevin
during his home services award cancer
down corner already tried took the
opportunities during development
meetings to try and get the best outcome
for his residence and protect ready from
over to government and increased focus
on a lighter note I know for us on this
side of the chamber we will miss his
constant supply of wine domes and
happily shared with us I for one wish I
could have benefited and his friendship
and his years of knowledge and
experience much longer thank you
that's what man
teacher model still have to say a few
words I first met Chris in 2010 I was
out counting on behalf of a prospective
Conservative candidate for grant award I
was on lock lane I knocked on the door
and I came to Chris black it was funny
as the realization dawned on me that I
was standing in front of the Lib Dem
opposition leader asking him if he'd
consider voting conservative in good
humor Chris assured me that I couldn't
count on his vote however he would be
happy to discuss local issues of
politics with me any time I liked well
over the years both the conservative and
an independent member of Council and I'm
very pleased
I did take Chris up on his offer on
several occasions his experience and
knowledge of Rochford history was
invaluable and his desire to speak up on
behalf of residency served it was
evident until recently on development
committee chris has been mentioned
before returned up and we share wine
gums as matters were being discussed and
that's something I would I will miss and
so tonight Chris one gun for me thank
you
No we move on to the actual business now
right and why apologies for absence have
apologies we counsel ashore down to the
will see to our substitute madness that
counselor cut Norfolk Council short and
counselor mr. Foy for counselor Wilson
Oh non members attending that's the news
snow wave of scale getting and q minutes
of the meeting have on 24th of August
2017 they have to meet sigh knows as a
correct and accurate record of that
meeting thank you item 5 is declarations
of interest as mrs. Kennedy council just
Baron on peculiar interest in item 6 and
7 justice I had nothing to do with
either of these applications
not period for being a member of the
Russian capital wall counselor and
admittedly that much right Thank You mr.
chairman an opportunity interest as I'm
counselor for the rugs districts with
your scratch waveforms in and also more
Council okay right on to item six just
for our visitors this evening the work
the way it works is that we will have a
presentation from our offices then if
there are any people who are already
registered to speak they'll be speaking
from accent of five minutes each and
then we go into the members discussion
after which they'll be around so the
first item is castle point in Rockford
adult community college for a Rockford
and who's taking this one
this time so inserts for reports as
though for members you consider the
report it must not the examination to
this applications welcome back to the
States
so on this movement one from point
forward or explains why got this little
piece of it then automatically remember
on the 20 July Memphis considered
application and the zero zero zero one
or two which is the residential
application for lunch wait there's a
perceived shortfall in parking provision
in connection to the ongoing use of the
sports page so this application
specifically this being submitted to
address that shortfall in connector
application and as the report clearly
identifies that this application is
aligned with the one on two application
so just go on and show you some slides
in terms of what's proposes instance one
of the key issues aces vision we have to
bring this application before members
who are yet to be consideration of the
residential application is fundamental
past addresses in that short but
nevertheless is an application is on
white which pops your pencil policy
advice essex hosting students submit as
a stand-alone application which is a so
what we have in comes us there and this
is i will show you the define red line
but that sees the the you ship the loop
here is the Community College and the
application sizes to the beer here
within this area of the egg chapter in
the sports page is important to to
emphasize that there's not encroach and
sports page I'll show some slightly
moments to then check that's the case of
the second slide
so we just gonna set out the physical
extent man of the location on the
development so the site is south of the
proposed residential development what
we've got here is the rectangular area
being 95 meters 95 meters in length by
approximately 20 meters in width will
show the layers we move on to the next
slide please
so this is just actually a shop looking
up from the south from the bottom the
sports pitches some sites is right on
the edge and basically as members will
appreciate from the previous slide
showing the red line there yet the site
actually is consistent with me
we expanded a little form of the actual
colleges College building itself so we
go on
so this is a bit slow
which [ __ ] us in Sydney so in terms of
the
and I would like I told it through but I
think that the support that I speak
right is as I'm showing me very selling
it so we can we can go to this light so
this is a shot of the sports pitches so
the cafeteria will be here and coming
out 20 meters in this direction from the
edge of the building what I'd like to
show us all of the machine all that I
was is a site layout showing the
relation of the car cracking to the
action sports pitches I'll just explain
ourselves acting with the Machine the
application also members will not only
report the application also seats the
principal consent or the safety of
two-dimensional buildings the purpose of
all the rental buildings one being will
be a minimum of 16 us the wall at all
that's great one of the buildings so the
principal percent or the society of to
be multiple buildings the site plan bad
that's great thank you
despite plenty of actually indicates
where the two-dimensional buildings will
actually be located solve all the
material appeals of the amount of
buildings at this stage is not critical
it is seeking consent for siting of
which is key because one of the key
consultants which the responses which is
included in the update a key part of
this development is to not only to
provide sufficient campaign for the
ongoing use of it but also sufficient
facilities which support the continuous
I keep changing the seventy and toilets
etc so the plan is is sufficient and
that it sets out the location of those
pitches and warm according according
with the specifications they die by
sports England what I would say is that
the applicants have been very proactive
in seeking an agreement with salt
England about the specifications all
those things for deliveries as part of
the sea by Glenda so currently Motilal
finish them as a lot they look like with
ensembles be sort of present we have
these sort of scale which is sufficient
for us to make decisions regarding in
public on the openness of the analysis
of all the issues so I think what this
slide seeks to shore is it's it's for
importance that there's no net loss of
small spaces and what this slide clearly
demonstrates is that you've got parking
or up to 50 vehicles in peril
configuration being served by the
central spire or Bank which will serve
the site and then you've got a layout
which Shores actually a reconfiguration
a sports which is but non net loss of
sports which is polishes
so it says that's that was a key
consideration for us as an authority
that was a key person
for sports in which I look at this case
in in some itself so move on Smith some
books that pump myself we've got a
section Troy Roberts the next light back
nothing something the report does
indicates that there was a slight the
French feel and waggle between if you
remember a few slides back there's a
little bit of lip but the end of lead-up
to the rear of the building so there's a
little bit of drop down probably not
benevolence is something announced
within those parameters so this section
one actually shows a very slight
gradient so the engineering operations
are liable to call de minimis there in
the ceiling incident evil planning terms
but that was being provided just ashore
come up to thee in reality access will
be gained by about central respite Lord
into the site the important thing to
emphasize here is indicated in the
report members bearing in mind that the
site is is open space it is windy this
means that mean about the actual
construction material is important to
emphasize this for a sweet so it's been
a culinary of 1400 square meters so
grass creatures are typical service
units you've got you're gone
assuming a National Trust property
whereby you smoke hash on piece of hash
tarmac it's a view or material that is
the people super grains
being or thus walk through its citizens
of in section 6 of the course of the
endless it mentions other material in
situations where service water drainage
issues that is and deposit lead by the
surface and I propose in this instance
its exhibit it serves a dual purpose
which is to reduce visual impact economy
character would be balanced if you like
and also survivors of allowing and
saltfish of rainwater into the ground
hence the next effect is there's normal
water draining of the small space as of
there is presently so I just want to go
through a few items before you consider
of what class back to the chair you'll
notice from the consultation section of
the report that assaults in live
initially require further information
but he is she being the delivery and of
the packing and the timing of it so just
to explain this effect theater if you
remember then actually the residential
application the packing that currently
exists was in place during phase form
but once is to connect those the
displaces of attacking which this
application addresses obviously in
connection with the use of the parking
it's mentioned in the report that the
spying role obviously opportune
the usable standard by the time to Phase
two of the residential C commences in
order to ensure that there is a
restricted access to the parking at the
time basically
so the consultation penzal note that
sports england initially request for
information enter the venue upon the
epithet of sporting England under point
three point six sporting the nominee no
objection is made to keeping the Vale
acquire is being that the name the time
another provision of the compact and
also the deep south of specification of
the actual amongst four buildings the
changing room this out in all that
explaining is of the no objection
initially watch the first place all the
time I empower the person not responded
that seems limited within the update
they keep concern that what should
perish and salt
this
it is something service various
altitude wasn't so remember
subjectiveness application as they
thought it was an appropriate
development in the limited am here
especially the community absolutely
taken away and the active this one's it
replicates this report or stronger cable
so it is as read really but is the the
the the principle here is is this the
structures proposed as part of the
development I in the demands for
building for providing electricity
supply were provided obviously an
acidity and then a minimum of 16
Spencer's changing space and basically
on that basis that specifications in
group with Essex focusing and Sport
England Sports England now as open in
the updates has in the kids that cousin
all objections the scheme providing that
also to safe as the mega the delivery of
the parking permission other delivery of
the municipal she
so there's no tax also from the occupant
and salami box both objections on on the
same basis that without the process a
little bit of excellent and the amount
of although they saw the end a friend
and the two conditions phasing the tight
so the key issues then just around up
then there's the key issues that in
terms of section finding the clipboards
bicycling material planning
considerations so as Mendoza Lords would
with duty bound to determine
applications in accordance with it
looking to provision all the development
plan and therefore the key issues are
the appropriateness other problems
between about so and I should find
important for intercept balances is is
is an appropriate then it points the way
in from it being so the feasible thing
about so the key issues for the boner
course as members will notice the impact
of the contract on the sports which is
in terms of weather swings who printed
this the ongoing use of the sports [ __ ]
isn't I think that slightly demonstrates
that voltages will will remain in use so
in that sense there was there is I would
judge that there's an improvement really
because the long the longevity of a can
use the small speeches is actually
he was buying parking but is aligned
right next to the sports page mrs.
purpose is repurposed all and that's all
the comments that we receive from sports
in England as well so in terms of the
the ongoing use it's it's probably a
next game and then in terms of whether
there's any visual time would write from
the proposed the government must develop
a point five point three to five point
one for the reports and five point one
to repose is the conclusion that's on
the basis of the materials use which is
is not given a hash is your appearance
when you're looking at the site of all
the sports pitches that the conclusion
reached an officer at all Bank resistors
in all demonstrable pitch length of
impact on openness this is not a comic
surface and also the most buildings
would be alignment within the new
residential developments if I were to
receive certain terms of its listing as
backdrop of don't form so on the
elements basically without support
interesting news so the service water
another being asleep the recommendation
there is a slight relation to the
recognition and one point for most ways
and what which has been terrified by the
applicants a point is raised regarding
the potential and sense of how one can
control and all quite useful
a 2005 uses for colleges and businesses
responded by indicating that at that
point of access to the back here from
the actual spine rod as suggested in
that is perhaps the knowledge with less
that concern that a bounty of could be
put in which has got some elements of
control the use by people using this
false [ __ ] out like to add also that
there is support bicameral ports to
deceive the very supportive no matter
they get noted in the report members
that elective support was received from
chemical cults in relation to this
developments that
it suggests attitude but I would say
that it is a corporate development being
about it serves a useful purpose in
terms of ensuring the continued use of
sports pitches as a team that has the
more demonstrable it shouldn't affect
the public character that or just the
need with the revised recommendation of
further condition attached in relation
to the provision of barriers as my
recommendation just double checking that
there is a and addendum to the report
that we've got four thousand six and
eight and seven make sure everyone has
got that
we thought a speaker mr. Butler as the
agent for this one plays dr. Lee five
minutes
you can know that - it's an omen
good evening the other one a long one
this is
okay good evening chair members and
officers I am Steven Butler from
bidwells
the planning consultant appointed by
Essex housing at Essex County Council on
this site this application is intended
to address the objection from Sports
England's that was received just before
the application for the refund from the
former head of Learning Centre on
graduating was presented to the july
plugin committee that application is the
next item on tonight's agenda and our
project architect is here to speak
inspected that's me
since july we have been liaison closely
with sporting Ian's to address this
objection namely that we needed to
provide the displacement parking
facility for the playing fields to the
south of the site so that the future use
of the playing fields not to be
prejudiced the carpark proposed by this
application addresses this objection
furthermore the proposed amounts of the
structures would contain changing and
toilet facilities for the users of the
plank bills the ham records this would
represent an improvement on the basic
limited facilities currently available
to the codes on sites the proposed
developments would be acceptable in
greenbelt owns the sport England now
raises no objection to developments the
Hamburg Colts are fully in support of
the scheme
crucially the improvements to the
facilities currently available to the
cult's a reliance upon approval upon the
approval of the application next up onto
my committee agenda I trust you will
take this into consideration about Roach
waiting for personal systemize thank you
okay this cancer Stanley indicated
pleased to see the microphone base you
don't need to stamp this one I'm pleased
to see that some functions have been
made for discharging water outside
however is the car parking facilities
going to be available before the
construction starts is one question as
the playing fields will he goes before
the towing especially during winter
we're making play football and also what
buffer zone has they're being put
between the playing fields and the car
volume so that the new residents when
they begin to occupy the premises have
some sort of say approaching or
something like that to the noises and
the fumes from the car park my
there they void in as much as maybe
you've got how many parking spaces there
are 50 felony a lot lot more as to we
already know that when they do start
playing football there is an Alford
offer spectatorship going on I don't
think that would be sufficient and I
think that the area that they drive into
soon it will be chocolate company cars
coming to Delhi there was a period of
times when they've football ain't you
they're near the non-members which is
trivial sector
make a chair I've got a number of
questions for the application for my
first of all pick it up on the car
parking spaces up Levy said it was fifty
how is that be calculated I've worked
out I think this I've got quite work out
when it's four or five inches if it's
more pictures upcoming that possibly
forty four cars because for the team
players what about the supporters and
what about support services for the quad
whereas Department for them secondly
there's obviously glad to be increased
parking assuming that the rest of the
site is developed there will be parking
within those roads on match days how is
that going to be controlled and there's
obviously a flashpoint there between the
potential residents I wasn't quite clear
where the demand for building was
correct but I think that I'm working it
out it's on the bit of the car park just
there yes will that require services put
in there particularly assuming there's
going to be toilets in there
waters and what-have-you and where would
happen connected up the speaker did
mention there that there was going to be
a potential control of the car parking
entrance to stop the residents used in
the car park that there are private job
opportunities at all that's nice so
that's that
they're picking up on that particular
point does that require a proposal to a
dentist and conditions I can answer that
last one quickly that's a good that's a
recommendation of the possible cancer
cut
so it just kind of things want to come I
chair I mean I used to go with my son to
these fields many many years ago he's
made many years ago near where he used
to play football locally I always
remember the pitches is this slightly
ranked if you like they're not quite the
square they're not little so there was
an interesting behavior from some
peoples of the people there you are but
when I'm going to be near rajendra cold
January moving cross late because I
didn't know there were no facilities
they were talking that you could use
people move et cetera as a spectator so
you know you can serve a holiday so I
think the provision of facilities their
net would be really really good going
forward and I think that would actually
improve it as far as that's concerned
I'm pleased to see I think that the
worthy that was going to go and I think
they're going to interfere with the
football would scepter going forward and
I just would like some clarification if
I made on the spine Road is it's
actually two cars with et cetera to
actually access it the officers of the
police just pile up that for me I'll be
very very important thank you very much
Who am I giving the questions no issues
on the timing of the work buffer zone
parking space and accessing the road
working right okay that leaves first
person notes also in terms of quality as
to when the car park is the needed
so I think the reports if I'm correct
actually basically it members July issue
orders he may remember that's only
residential planned it showed a parking
provision in that area to be occupied by
phase two was phase one was actually
developed so they meet with a car
parking provision is going to kick in on
the commencement of days - so the the
contract information has got to be
complete with all the facilities - for
building on services really that's the
commissioner that's all England are
proposing so the fact that must be
completed in for an available operation
whose price for pencils of face to
residential
residential application the second
question was raised regarding the
pollution etc in terms of normies
evidence if I correctly see this from
the next presentation there was a
headphone Rishon on the southern part of
the residential application site and
we'll see from site plan that what
what's included along the southern
boundaries packing in the open courtyard
area so the actual living accommodation
which this time proved anyway is some
way away from that southern Avenue the
site which is the northern edge of the
of the compact basically so it's that
some way back so we've got it here that
we in terms of parking so what being the
honestly applying shores is a hedge
along here in terms of subjective
condition you know we can look at if
it's needed if it's if it's justified as
a as a requires a plan in addition if
it's just put on that basis and then the
authority members can consider the
merits of the type of landscaping levin
would've liked to seen here too
to get against any perceive that impacts
of noise and student pollution but just
a note that I'm super built form
although this is part the residential
community face to the actual built form
itself as quite silly fact this is a
problem the bunting with attract the
there was an issue of balance the
advocacy of the packing I went to the
further now to an email we received from
the agent regarding this exact issue so
I'd like to mean it if possible the east
s expenses of council parking status to
be too lazy users uselessly the 20
spaces should be provided third pitch a
spawn space for attendance today to
seize the initiative spectator seats
means that the standards are significant
the various scales of sports pictures at
once but the polls wasn't a local
Association complain for a default
football pitches of different sizes
which has support arrange the in troops
the Essex County Council parking
standards that maximum Statler's
software ATC's could potentially provide
adjacent the pitches for whether the
existing claim it just feels much less
intense instance possibly
fortunately for example and hence not
require the maximum provision of car
parking spaces ascetics in the standards
but also 50 spaces are enough to cater
for future packing demand because they
would simply replace and relocate an
existing arrangements the existing house
family including underwater is similar
in size and pence horses do not
represent the reduction in Franklin
spaces the proposals have thought the
full support of Humber thoughts uses all
the sports which is just to clarify that
fact that's the D feedback effectively
agents I think just in terms of then
there's assisting members consideration
this matter I think the key issues
consider given the displacement of the
packing is one is immense of massive set
themselves question will will this
provision make matters made that will
the net effect be any worse than the
current situation in fact is whatever
lenders conclude that then the status
horsemen saying the faculty members to
deliver its all the racks there was
another point that they incidents with
clarification on the purpose of
attacking schwartzen-muth being involved
in working at this scheme ugly in terms
of
there's no objection if there was any
shortfall of packing commenced it with
us with also the force flow switches and
scores England would have raised that as
an issue I suppose England has not
objected to the application there's a
question regarding services so it's
indicated that toilet facilities and
electric will be provided did I'm not
sure chair and says what for the
classifications are quite by then with
it on that point there's a point
regarding the potential control of
backpacking and I think there was a
mention of perhaps residents using the
boat with residents using this power
pack areas all the spill accommodation
the car parking provision in phase one
and phase two of the development
provides as to car parking spaces the
dwelling the haunting weddings in which
aseptically face warm developments and
31 parking spaces were placed to develop
it's my opinion members that it'd be
more I think the more the concern is and
some of the people presume that they
make us want to insert that I don't
think that the issues ever going to be
so much residence back in a bad way I
hear what many was saying and then into
the spine rule of the last person with
the spine or the swangle is standard
broad that would be it would be an
adoptable status so that's one another I
think that's what I've jotted down with
it my fault I've dealt with those
questions can step up where you just
stand up I relate through the facility
the more permanent structures that
consideration that was taking to account
for always that dismiss due to Greenbelt
considerations
he's the facility see that on the
drawing English like this too
they separate man they don't know that
that's planning consideration to be
honest
and if there is there any indication as
to the number of changes in the changing
facilities how many how many teens are
likely to be able to occupy these
facilities
okay
not this area so do we
50 parking spaces at the moment there is
conversation about 100 spaces where much
nice roach Avenue mr. a rich way and and
you are riddled with the other proposals
are going for it is just read to me just
on that face
I do have serious energy values
yeah
because the castration
mr. bone thank you sorry
I think they issues always really around
the National Building to the party
I've got concerns over parking but I
understand that about Maximus and it
probably means those the bigness of
reason the non-marking of these things
spaces I think aware that if you don't
have space is marked cars take up more
room than designed to I know that we are
able to mob the disabled spaces those
emails about the standard spaces I think
you've got space inside mark 450 cuz
they don't get me because I don't think
it would be sufficient so I think they
should be not they don't know this
experience section in this case and I
understand why people across great
I'm sure there's way to do it the second
issue around the dimensional buildings
on condition for we say that certainty
gain regarding the vitamin C or anything
else of structures I'm not sure what
certainty
happiness my certainty that we may not
really as I say that what happened
there's no clarification of what we're
after
in that condition I think is important
can we be more specific to any other one
there's one that wishes to be canceled
scepter
yes nectar chair it's really good
clarification with these flexibilities
can I ask whether they are of the
quarter cabin style or are we thinking
retainer to start
many other members wish to read anything
I'll ask the questions to be answered in
them myself and okay just on the point
quietly which happens the application
particulars don't include the details
hints to me the condition so they could
be that they could be equal to having
starred will contain the purpose of the
conditions
council always questioned
right so you've mentioned the municipal
building so as as on occasion so in
terms of the I did see I've seen the
beginning of the presentation at the the
actual site area or the commercial
buildings are shown on the plan that
makes it begins into that sets out the
scale so they don't think about
footprints but in terms of snake Heights
and weight is determined by the pitch
there but in terms of heights it's
correct to say that that's the purpose
of the conditions to work up the
specification I think sporting military
event and in person so there's so in
terms of addressing advocacy of male and
female usage a fact the people if I was
a rather than planning issue that
would've still looking at points of
objections of sporting would about as
much issues to do with whether the
implementing need the actual facilities
sort of adequate given before she's my
chest I like clarify the fish sauce
okay I think exactly sorry thank you Jim
the question was around the condition
before it was around the facilities for
whom
whoever it was around the surface be
datum and and lighter material finish or
building we there's no mention of what
we regardless except when relations are
hiked in that condition or what
regardless centers materials in that
condition bear in mind it's not or not
that's what England issues on the
country health issues particularly issue
these buildings I mean read notes on the
agent that was issued to be appropriate
before that that was the question
impediment and the certainty will read
that under sensor doesn't specify
so in terms of the condition that that
is the purpose of the condition is to
nail that exactly what is a portrait of
generally speaking amongst all buildings
and the more 2.7 meters height they
named the of the grandeur but in terms
of that is the purpose of the condition
is to ensure the knee or back down it's
basically buying the condition so if
they were proposing a shiny finish for
example you know will weaken as an
authority I've got the score to consider
what is acceptable in terms of the team
will finish that one with the agreement
often council is polite suggests we
might do that with the concentrations of
all the campuses not contention they're
nice guys for safety and then there was
a Polish
slowly reading comments bugs hacking is
if you notice that currently currently
in the package area poultry a building
isn't so accepting I think with one in
perspective it is it is the three
bullets and that is Westerham doesn't
mean much as any worse because of the
answer is that members the degree that
is if the material fact but by the same
token it's only plan to have a
discussion isn't certified well have any
replacements the net five recommendation
five can I suggest an amendment for that
which simply has marked in an
appropriate style because there it
various methods that are cheap and
simple enough without causing any any
particular arm numbers fear agreement
with that well specifically on those
that were just on the stubs or program
or so that's a small amendment so
condition fine okay thank you can't be
couple of questions six point six nights
and two it doesn't upload it says that
we can parking you
occasional planning during the blah blah
blah including any parking spaces for
the mobility so it is including Joby's
hard service suit and mark telecom
provider who is it they would not
attention in that yeah well conditioned
part you know I feel well adequately
address that you know that's a step so
you know yes just wanted to pick up on
points in capital I raised that said but
the style and Depot Christmas amount of
the buildings should be in consultation
about more council members we have
recommendations in personal place I know
Peter things also virtually exhausted
everything I've noticed on the growing
of the area too
maskull buildings
anything
it could be some additional parking
spaces on this
regular access under some stress around
different access
okay we have six conditions 22 on the
main document of a seventh one on the
addendum we have a small adjustments
margin condition for including
consultation with ward councillors we
have a small amendment to item five
about marking the bays in an appropriate
way so you go to the vote those members
in favor of the recommendation for
approval please
is
right item seven and again some
information on the addendum with that
one it's the same site former adult
community learning colleagues wrote wait
watch
so depends us on this presentation
like okay I'm just gonna set up Mendes
Bob CC 215 the report this is another
favorite horses and so I prepared the
presentation a certain magnet that we
consist of Johnson and me on the scheme
that we look at that on the 10th of July
and then we're going to look at
so I'll give you people view the
proposals that I'm going to run through
the items to learn the point ones for
lightning sir excuse me attractive you
possibly had something like that in
France we should see that
life's tough
these
that's that
okay sorry members in return so just to
run through that link this is a penis as
possible so we'll give you a brief
overview of the what we've considered
previously just to drop in entries and
then I'm going to give you a brief
overview of the of the points of one
that they belong to land that they're
being numbered between hit me up they
report with reference to the any issues
and in terms of dealing with your cream
sauce and the needs of combat is also
common in the potential for further
information everybody applicants the
best specific matters which are all in
see this application with the third be
with the included educational policy
policy position for
give up nice intoxication because the
posting position has sort of become tea
or agave plants and then going to take
you back through to the slides
looking at what's being submitted
citizen's arrest all tissues so if we
start off we'll see that's defecation is
right through is rupees so I'm just
showing you a few slides of being
application to show you on the 20th of
July obviously that's not where I think
most members will give that meeting sly
so called soupy just
but we know what size were talking about
between emails me
so mr. Barnett was obviously steam was
convicted that at least in Phase II
phase one phase two of developments 14
weddings which from the outset were
stated not to be so from the outset 14
weddings then it was going to be there
was no the new traditional affordable
housing and in that sense the second
phase is see two developments actually
as Mendizabal notes from reports about
that marry if the need should be
presidential application of independent
living information it doesn't fulfill a
requirement for affordable housing the
housing office so they're not your
friends soul relatives the nominees
rights although this references in their
members in this report to the delivery
of affordable housing which was such a
sexual assist agreements that periphyton
the updates to avoid some event that
that isn't actually a requirement and
that thought I think there's a proposal
soon or myths fact
this [ __ ] about section or six that
relates the fourth wall I'm using so
that's the supposed to show you the many
styles we might get what it look like
some of the elevations okay so that was
that was the student seniors now they
hope the things emphasized event
received well on that it's like the
Mormons I think that's quite a key I
think that's quite a key slide actually
that we'll compare that Norway exhume be
the drawings nice is it now but I'm sure
members remember Lee seeing in the
meeting 20th of July but the site levels
between watch way and this side actually
plot by significantly who's standing
then the Catholic area in comes the
little day this like the differential at
the western aspect of the site that
employees is probably good meters
between Catholic level and the
gallbladder problems way and in terms of
asking lots of significance both
backslide they're discrete view from
which way is the independent living
accommodation then on the left as we
look at it although they would appear to
us to be allowed max they no higher than
these to be story time counseling
dwellings here I think the site slightly
drops away as well so I think it's
important when members consider design
issues to consider to bear that sort of
elevational theme in mind
or sitting go through team all the
slides elevations of a move on
Rob Saleem updates that was phase one
and then here was the banking mitigation
was phase one went ahead
so we really thought worthy views that
were shown the mix of women types us
could write reports so brick with
frontage parking along Broadway the the
dwellings were set back slightly further
than the actual living accommodation so
typical time expires so if we move on in
terms of
back here
so since the members from north and they
were 11 points of grain in terms of the
issues that were raised so the report is
speaks for South Korea in terms of will
put us all through those points so the
sustainable parking solution has been
addressed by the previous application
moving visitors parking spaces and a
report of the fact that was point and I
was one to realizing a couple minutes so
just to clarify that there's two compact
and spaces for each wedding in Bayswater
right steam and thirty-one parking
spaces within two developments so that
really that deep the different wanting
to be funny to I'm twenty three
addresses the concerns I stood at the
reins and the 22 the lastly there is a
point regarding connectivity an
operation of access rule the respective
disability s6 the access of
congratulations that this was what this
in order to be able and say but
regardless oppose the developments turns
out that in terms of the Planning
Commission's of these condition and
provide some certainty in terms of i1
impede access has maintained the
successes like but also there's also a
separate lead alteration on SS
seek out the access of in terms of
points open wonderful places not
considered that is a-- is an issue of
concern there was a question of thing
and that point forward and then it's
likely right which is point five in a
report the use of the outdoor living
space so the agents have actually
addressed that under 5.1 5.2 mental
notes on a seven point five
there's a coffee shop as a hair salon
suite a storage facility and has
following formal quiet language and as
we hopefully look at some of these
images we can try and get an
appreciation we look at the designers
shouldn't focus on on the pro but living
space with work relates to the
impractical accommodation and south is
the earth all living air is intrinsic
rather than accommodation business then
impact on of of accommodations it's it's
a cognitive space then was that question
regarding the phasing of the rule that
how that aligns with visas one to the
development they must be another person
between this application but so the
world has to be and equip doesn't it's a
separate development man which is just
as prudent anyway so I won't the sort of
mention thing more about that unless
this questions
and then was the contributions force
community sports facilities that's been
practically has been addressed rate in
terms of the separate occasional just
considered the baton itself is a
contribution and that's the very same
point what is seven point two and then
the there's been a response from Essex
and sulfate was the application that's
included as an updated so application of
the tiny portrait and there wasn't a
response
it's a responses covered
and I think in terms of the of the
authority receipt that is you know in
some of the use of an application
conditions those conditions be worded
either similarly R and then signals of
speed advice but we won't necessarily
use exactly the same conditions but the
spirits of internally embassy to achieve
anything the same but we just have the
bit of caution perhaps about but they
are stagnant conditions so we're going
to check those concerns to see whether
they're appropriate for that
circumstance but we made sure that we
kept see that's why in most English
shoes so the cracking the mobility
ceases to be actually responded by key
agent that the point nine point one of
the report the site is designated such
that the ease of mobility for millions
of common in the hominin space is
facilitated incorporating incorporating
open air isn't running for common areas
but in terms of the agents actually
suppress this also in
under the points for the convocation
quite by the names it's anyone's fault
and it's really
packing mobility scooters on this on the
front page then so provision of a
dedicated scoots exactly facilitators
running for as well as having accessible
apartments ensure the long-term
flexibility views so that the scheme
meets the needs of any degree that is
more adaptable to call this or looking
for other needs change
this requires less expensive independent
but in deciding that needs it is
important for designing assault response
seems to address between dependability
impact of white noise it wasn't Smith
but others something that was living
craft attention so we haven't think we
need to add on that specific aspect and
then we move on to the design slide
yeah it was like a laxative plan France
fight go through these in turn I'll
explain about these so since the thank
you so hot on page seven points and
report as pointed method learn point one
of the words they so the bottom of page
some points that I'd for members
attention to additional plans which have
been submitted since the deferment
throughout the application so there are
some changes so one of the the reason I
want to show you this plan is is that
members will appreciate that landscaping
is an essential part of any pelvis mean
it's an intrinsic part of design and
what I'd like to sort of point out to in
terms of these creative sort of green
areas along the frontage so this is an
amended plan and I think it's the
smaller offices
it's not later lunch they planned and
basically what it is it's extending to
the landscaping on the system and
there's going to be page phone filled
with trees along here and we'll see from
the amended elevation drawings you know
how sub trees are integrated into the
schema into the stage banyan tree this
is the spending with the open field and
mostly the sports which is down here so
that landscape plan that fact that there
was a series of documents submitted to
us so they received the stamp on the 6th
of September which looked at design they
were not it's fair to say that there are
no fundamental changes in the design of
the independent living accommodation and
I'll go through some slides to show you
these changes to the elevation thickness
of the 40 weddings
I mean satisfactory as one skip fact
that yours commitment to incorporating
landscape as part of this design so even
into the landscaping along here involve
the next slide please
so
or watches for this the next slide I was
going to show you this was a landscaping
plan very similar to the previous slide
and what the applicants has done they
have provided a landscaping plan showing
where you know the treatments of banyan
trees
she isn't helping miss my friend isn't
sorry about less but my control
the next slide the next slide basically
there we go so typically helpful but
there was me so I just wanna go through
this light in all the but obstacle the
specification
so yeah so it's about that very green
and it assured you what we've got here
is you know is obviously we're not going
to read them as a certain pressure in
all sorts of police we send them
straight is that is aligned with the
planner to show you which is basically
showing the species that please to be
planted field the H species to be
planted
so basically been streets in accordance
with the previous line that I saw is a
there's a real commitment to the
landscape from the speed and that is
what this one's yours greater than here
Mendez will see just about we've got
here it is critical what we've got here
is some advanced incorrect thinking some
lines here so this is the landscaping
plan indicating the treatment of
boundaries so as we come into the site
what we got here is we haven't got
possible things when you've got
stonewalled
we've got brick walls but blue denotes
brick walls and side entrance
we've got more image which announced a
wall and rail boundary which is 1.2
meters high we've got the yellow which
is a brick wall of mpany metre high or
where the tall small fencing which is
possibly members like a bit all new on
but also fencing is pretty much limited
to following the boundaries between the
RIA Gavin's backing onto one another
here so one will not see other than tour
sport fencing behind will be a page
boundary here the portal pacing will be
basically limited to the rear aspect so
when one is commencing the slate it will
not be greeted with one panini - hi all
suppose fencing an act that is something
that I think is is boss all it's a good
aspect of the scheme to move on next
slide please
so again back that is what we got well
we've got some updates in fact that is
inundated street scene and basically it
is the people to deserve so that is the
latest instance that's actually been
submitted and if we compare it with the
next one which is also the original
street scene so members would not be
able to discern what the differences so
I will point them out to you only there
isn't any difference on the independent
living elevations it's acknowledge that
that mark is what it is and it stands
for there's not deliberate attempt to
change the design about it it is what it
is in terms of that the detailing of
these townhouses there are some subtle
changes with which the agency has
actually pinpointed is it because
actually see from this drawing
but there are some rick means something
which I'll show you in in a while there
is some basically there's an
introduction of horizontal solder
courses on these dwellings so it's just
brick funding things in this area here
so the answer subtle but they're trying
to sort of provide a little bit variety
to the to the frontage and then we
constructed stone cells so in terms of
windowsills will be only this very
chilling in the tubules there along the
window souls and the window openings
have been adjusted and materials that
can happen so this is five change in the
in the sort of the frame in a good
windows to start a bit of beth to them
to the windows etc so they are supple
and it is difficult to actually project
amounts but as the changes have been
made just a tiny kitchen writing
is for objects like images or weights
which have been living elevations so
what we've got there is what we've got
there is the first the first slide is
the front elevation of independent
living as you asked seen from rocks race
doctor and the things sort of almost
slide and it shows tree planting along
the front so there's obviously the
collapse there is falling fast the areas
the second picture on the screen is the
sign so if we were looking at it from
the inner spining or anything at the
side elevation of it and then the third
image is the rear aspect looking through
the cold outta here here from the
parking at the rear from the south
looking through up the rear aspect of
this elevation so I move on to the next
slide
c19
so again 0-9 is to see how that's folks
like they also plans
and they've just shown to the variations
in brick would pack nothing less than
mean that is on top of that on 11
such slight the piping see your back
so imagine that's the your notes I'm
trying to show that applause from the
original listen to lots of changes there
just support changes but I that was best
to shorten so when we want to sustain we
through post point all Thirteen's line
13 is the house deep automation
so they are circle so we've got there
we've got a mixer Brendan Bret clearly
that's what it's yours there's some
solar panels within the room space as
well and this is same pattern moving all
the way to through to I'd like to have a
look at the soon
fight the slide 18 19
I'd like to if possible wrong the hold
the ctrl shorts in a word I think what
I'd like to sort of find there is to do
that while the significance so the
applicant has climbed in order to apply
to service in order to encapsulate this
developments in terms of pointing
members the true to steal the picture of
the developments in terms we will
achieve a positive place making the
applicants has prepared informations
assist members instance situation this
matter
tense the flight through we've had some
waiting problems so we're not sure we
can show you the actual flight through
the video version you know we appreciate
them the software challenged assess the
dollars on the basis of two-dimensional
drawings and assessing its
appropriateness what was the place will
be like what place will feel white and
what the environment it will provide
those having difficulty to come back to
the state so obviously in fact what I
would say about that is is that that is
computer graphic in
which achieves scale depiction of what
that would look like once the ballot or
once the landscape was sufficiently
natty work that is in terms of relative
to all other parameters that is
basically depicts how it would be
wanting from archway we want the next
line
okay so that's the spying rules you can
see some different pallets of materials
how they beat the middle them's the
built form is sort of articulated around
the main access way the curve in the
road the actual brick wall that the blue
line on the landscape who's seen which I
showed which is this brick wall so
provides a positive entrance to the site
so in terms of treating
okay so that's the view from the east
isn't it from the horses obviously
flying through but that's the demon the
problem but would be the being pumped
into the fields to these things think
about it you can see the solar panels
and falls on the roof which actually
from Road level has been clarified with
the applicant with all three panels will
not be visible apart from a few
millimeters if one was actually walking
along wrong train there's ends up
remember this taken fall from final
Apple so in terms of avoid these are
going to be removed along with spine
injury there is a positive attempt to
sort of replant to serve the
developments the trees that are they
currently do it beneath we've honest
with others and obviously there's an
effort to to mitigate that in the form
of agent replanting
there we go and that's a shot from the
southeast aspect so there is a tree
there is a top terrace there and I think
members were clearing in the month of
July meeting about safety
there are various dancers are compliant
with with the regulations in that
respect
okay so that's I think that is quite a
telling images and set in terms of this
interaction to the parking space the
planting you've got areas here work with
their students and where people can mill
around and in this area that you know in
terms of coffee shops in consulting
rooms so the idea is it's it's a credit
Plaisance
safe secure environments but it does
it's the idea is that it's also open
it's not fenced in in any way which is
very important and that's a the looking
looking up the spine role in a northerly
direction if you like and this would be
the role which I believe that would be
lead into disability Essex don't you so
what we've got there is that they'll be
there is an attempt to sort of use
different types of brick that means to
just break up the elevations and just
add in thrust
that's it that's that's really looking
at the entrance way to walk straight
again I'm not sure there's any other
song each one
that's not what so I don't know in terms
of leaves just quite passed the point
okay okay so I'm just moving on the
recommendation and this so in terms of
the design itself
these changes are supple but incremental
II I do believe that they do it the
difference in terms of breaking up the
elevations of the dwellings in
particular the landscaping I feel is
relevant and in terms of I've just
referred here point one point five point
five point one aids and the original
players like one of the policies which
is application basically
many of these issues encapsulated by
policy each finding dm2 and number one
is there an appropriate mix of dwellings
so that we've heard the saw in that
respect and I'd like to just refer the
fall so moving on so my recommendation
its are the provisions of the National
planning policy framework bear in mind
that we have to take decisions of
accordance with national policy and in
that what the National Planning possibly
looking in the case is as follows honest
performance designers should contribute
positively to make this place is better
for people planning decision should
ensure that the government's solution
wild establish a strong sense of place
of the Micra potential of the site and
responsible character while not
preventing a corporate innovation to be
a Satanist
environments under vision attractive as
a result of good architecture and profit
one state pain and these points covered
by point five point four four original
reports and it's covered all the way
through one point but everything
revolved so it's my view that these
improvements noticeable the scheme
fulfills all criteria of the national
planning policy framework in terms of
what a dispositive esteem fulfills the
provisions of the local development
framework of the kinds of policies the
landscape in which an intrinsic part of
the design elements it's worthy of notes
as variations in binding treatments
brick walls and edge planting so in
terms of the addendum members names will
note that the constants of the event
under sports in will now does not object
into the would be the solutions finally
Osaka application s excite which has now
responded and as an object as a scheme s
Expensify so other than the design I've
responded and they
I would just us because this was
received today something I know it could
not be included any addendum and in
terms of design this is from senior
design consultants he's reviewed
application I'll just read the site of
the developments quantum layouts
appearance are considered high quality
that's a clear against the 12-time
Paris's Reuters which however simple
construction of a contemporary style the
independent living units design is
acceptable for the site basically in the
life that there be no or grinding
architectural style in the surrounding
area which is a mix of peerless file to
presence technologies the flat roof
elements of the apartment block once
Thomas leading keeping the surround
impatient buildings provides the
opportunity for elevations which are
considered a keeping in terms of scale
and a mistake on careful review of the
layouts plans and elevations the overall
scheme is considered to be of high
quality and there is no years or so in
certain movie follows the recommendation
there is one revision to the
recommendation it's the clarity provided
on the whole of homes in evidence the
the provisions as a new end of someone
in a a 7 a.m. they should be emitted
baby the movies for pointing or
comparison so at least be noted and also
recommendation moving forward with with
again
but with initiative of conditional 16
which relates the form or housing which
is leading us about carrots and
Widerberg the scheme does not actually
require there's no more time using so
it's it's my conclusion actually that
the balance is acceptable and in many
respects is an example our design which
in corpus innovation we have three
speakers on this one
firstly stands for softly from the
council
chair members officers and residents in
addition to the objections rated in by
to 7 on page 7.32 we would like to have
the following context
the Pawnee application mentions future
storage the Samba 16 2015 use on air
state the Paris pumps taken a survey of
the routes between this development
local shops and other community
amenities we have found the width of the
pathways as well for number and location
of roc curves to be an issue that
currently frustrates our elderly
residents and those with mobility issues
residents on this development will
immediately find this a barrier to
engaging with our community of
businesses serious thoughts detailing
pressure needs to be placed on the
section 106 and this is council council
to ensure that passive Rochford that
this new community will engage with in
the easily reach and that a benefit is
felt by the population of Washington as
a whole especially our elderly residents
and those with mobility issues we would
also call on this council our
representatives on a discount council
our enemies and our residents used to
development should it be improved to
focus on following issues currently
effective Waterford it will only have
increased pressure demand
the parachutes tirelessly trying to
excuse 20 mile-an-hour zone in and
around the center eruption this Newton
elegantly placed further need around the
central Roger vehicle was dissuaded to
ensure that residents are safe the local
speed watch often record motorists
reaching 34 miles an hour over on these
roads this new development needs to be
considered alongside any current and
future business so and our third weights
that need to ensure that our pathways
and protocol are adequate motor to see
the loss of its banks and a supermarket
leaving just a couple of convenience
stores and one small sales business some
distance in this development very few
elderly residents take up online banking
or even cash machines preferring to
speak to a cashier whilst if services
currently looked at by the post office
this replaced increased pressure on this
facility and the other banks branch the
tooth or a very early residents more
needs to be done to encourage businesses
of certain community to set up and fly
to this town finally public transport is
becoming less frequent the furies
providing connections from Rockford to
Southend properly Iranian pressure needs
to be put on the current operators or
worked on encouraging other operators to
provide at least transport service that
all of our residents and those at this
development commutes
thank you okay I'll set and speak is
just around 7:00
good evening my name is Laurie as a
cinema I'm an architect associates any
great architects thank you for that me
to speak in support of this application
bill this is Hazzard folks team that
watch waves under deliver sixty units of
independent living accommodation
fourteen family dwellings quite
acceptable residential units and totally
independent living is a new concept
which is designed to provide new housing
care and support to one or more other
people it is Essex housings intention to
move as far away as possible but the
traditional model of institutional care
to care in the community where people
can live independently and with dignity
in their own homes all they require with
the independent living accommodation
there would be a 50/50 split of private
and affordable accommodation within a
proposed development as a whole mr.
quest forty-one percent before award
region which significantly exceeds the
policy requirements it should be
considered that this provision is
proposed on sites where vacant building
credit would be applicable the
applicants therefore justifiably reduce
the affordable housing significantly but
is choosing not to because the wider
public benefits independent living
proposal dreams are optional this
previously developed sites within
walking distance of the town center is a
highly sustainable location but most
development working with officers we
have formulated a scheme that we believe
is both attractive and acceptable
against planning policy importantly it
would retain the bid and access to
disability assets as it is legally
obliged to do demolition of the existing
unlisted building on the site and they
lose the new development to optimize the
use of the site furthermore the Highways
Authority has no objection to the
proposal was including the imagine
parking proposed for the independent
information and private market units
both being at my esteem would accord
with green-backed policy mechanism
because if it was previously developed
land
in terms of the housing design the
development will feature six linked
attached houses with a meet with an
amused setting facing onto rochway this
design provide a welcoming attractive
frontage and screams the wider
development behind the existing brick
and railing wall along the wash bay
frontage will be refurbished and a new
substantial and attractive landscape
Spirit will be provided to replace the
old and diseased cherry trees thus
representing us nificant appearances
facing the new three-story Independent
Living who ended up by East the side of
the geese primary building form of the
independent living block is divided into
Bay's main more than three apartments in
the ninth across each of these lanes the
brickwork balconies and canopies or
alternates reduce the scale appearance
and mass in the elevation gardens and a
density landscape boundary would face
the bills to reduce the visual impact of
the development as a common photovoltaic
panels would be installed to the
rooftops of the rooftop of the
Independent Living Building to assist
assist in providing a sustainable
development a stunning landscape roof
terrace kitchen trees plants seats and
to the purveyors who provide residents
with fantastic views of the Australian
countryside while also helping to stop
buildings from the fields the
Independent Living Building to the be
open to non-residents who would be
encouraged to use the potential
facilities a coffee shop restaurant
hairdressers etc so that the development
becomes at the community card and
crossed to the contributor community of
rupture space 431 casters provided to
the independent living which is
surrounded by public and private gardens
to mitigate the visual impact of the
park now careful consideration has been
given to the setting of the whole
development by providing tree like but
of us brick boundary walls and
high-quality familiar materials
throughout including high quality
brickwork cast stone sills soldier
course detailing and other materials
vernacular to the area this produces an
attractive development for their local
business approach work in this respect
the development the comparables the
recently approved independently in a
scheme at copy sports Hendry
for example award-winning schemes
including the homeless shelter
marketplace of Colchester and the
multi-award-winning scheme that need all
be able to parlay deserve belief this
development by fantastic benefits rush
hood basin in fact
cantankerous team comparable to many
mates for examples and most importantly
that is compliant opposed by therefore
respectfully request that you support
your opposite recommendation to approve
this application will benefit the
district thank you thank you
our final speaker is mr. transom
but to encasement that was that yeah yes
place in France of living with time when
they were of the development and
speaking in opposition to the definition
of the building just going to set my
timer
chairman and councils I wish to
highlight the negative impact of the
proposed demolition of roads for
Manhattan Community College which has
also functioned in the past as a youth
center an ammeter dramatic rehearsal in
performance space in the sixties and
seventies and Secondary Modern School
from 1937 to 59 such a destructive
action will spirit watch this town
center release historicity and its
people of church members past learning
and dramatic activities whilst not
having any objections to the new
developments general purpose I strongly
oppose the annihilation of before
Manhattan Community College billion to
demolish the entire building rather than
conserve and integrate its fabric into
the present and future looking an
irreversible bad design decision and
rather thoughtless considering the
potential and the living residents may
well have been schooled in this now
endangered building we do not have to
look far for examples of progressive
conservation remote return such as the
residential conversions of the former
Royal Mail
office and police station currently in
progress not to mention the exemplar
hospital boiler house I strongly
encourage and approached since of these
redevelopments and a barrage that
retains the respective sites significant
Midlands historic values that was
distinctiveness and notions of civic
pride having studied the officers
reports specifically a section focused
on design points eleven pages seven
point seven and a little date it is
indicated that the agents have no
intention to change the design a
position that feels both arrogance and
contemptuous with local residents
feelings
additionally the proposed subtle
architectural amendments seem to allude
to the very building to be demolished
and the same way they can only be read
as tokenism and if this proposal goes
ahead will stand as a reminder of what
has been lost
that is to say authenticity and
conservation replaced by the pastiche
and destruction further I asked the
committee to consider including the
building on the local list because it
clearly meets their architectural
historic and street scene criteria
regarding architectural importance the
building features a unique deco to the
lintel featuring the 1937 construction
names and Essex County Council three
sinks and blue or triangle walled garden
structure five period brickwork and
generally gardens daily of time
regarding historic importance that
building is locally distinctive in
largely
historically important to local people
and his representative that would find
municipal building designed with the
1930s also an architectural photograph I
made this building was selected for the
50 sick as it open exhibition the
largest and most prestigious open arm
events in the county they bought
recognition of the building's importance
in the history of education in England
additionally as building provides a cure
for Philemon reminiscence and
intergenerational storytelling which I
have experienced through face-to-face
conversations and via the online module
district community archive regardez
Street scene the building has
contributed positively to the character
of roadway since 1937 for 80 years and
spans one third of the south facing
aspect arguably the building is the
streets and West Road fits the fine
architectural assets considering the
aforementioned it might also be prudent
it invites historic England carry out an
impartial and full assessment of the
educational building with the
committee's recommendation I am willing
and able to make this application
immediately finally I implore that the
committee's support adding the buildings
of the local list in the first instance
championing a protective approach and to
my own the agents go back to the drawing
board and rethink and implement a more
sensitive community focused approach
rather than the main intentions
the designing position I hope these
additional thoughts help preserve our
heritage for both independent living
residents and our future generations
thank you for your time thank you
members for the sake of clarity can I
just go over the recommendation that
we're talking to it's set out on the
addendum may 15 to 20 heads of condition
that are printed on page 7.50 of the
report - item 60 plus the additional
takes because they need em that's a
little bit confusing but that's that's
what we're talking turtle
so counts the Stanley you indicated some
time ago
quite read in front of me and writings
to it but always that height joy this
would be able to see any children
walking through the site driving out in
fact their terms
I don't know how people's bedrooms there
are in those houses patient could be
kind and you could tell us if that meets
the requirements for parking stains or
those vices you don't spit on the plane
doesn't show in beans being storage of a
beans rice beans that sort of thing on
the side can't see any beans they're
actually on my inside the houses or
something
and on the road convey rights negative
is that maybe put for more than the two
vehicles if somebody was to park their
vehicle outside of their premises could
you still get a beautiful cross and not
just a meaning I mean a proper car a
full-size Jack Ewing or something like
that which some residents will have the
University so they care and the other no
members wish to speak on this one okay
that's the Williams structure is it
adequate to support this many many
minutes passes very narrow emotion I've
closed a beautifully if there is fear in
fact of disability scooters motorized
wheelchair wheel chairs etc I could
with us then I motocross because he
wrote this application is division one
football opportunities that could be
improved and what about there's a little
way to put one there sweetly opposite of
water rose this be implemented to help
making church in this area of business
with nobility I really would like to see
this I developed very concerned
regarding that I mean the access to the
promotion and our lights to have some
form of conditions that this is looked
at okay that's a step there
they've checked the number of questions
and species similar lights previous
speaker first of all the Edition 10 my
document states that a condition require
nexus one maintains the store features
where the whole time I'd also like to
that amended to include disability Essex
nearly there doesn't seem to be any
provision for maintaining access these
are very negative rule here when this
development does take place or if it
takes place yet what facilities will be
put in place with regards to vehicles
guide in and out of the site
particularly it will wash going out onto
the roads there is a big concern about
paths particularly from the site up into
central rush that they're not in the
best of conditions the rug itself is not
the being the best of conditions and I
would suggest that the road doesn't need
to be repaired until such time as the
development is complete but I would like
to see condition please based on as you
- the paths are 106 agreement
look at that repairing improving and
making the access from the site to
little central boxes put in place with
regards to the wall council standing
picked up on the bit over to pick up
about where that particular vehicle in
the picture is coming out there's a bit
of a blind spot coming out there I think
that needs to be relooked at I take them
there that the slightly more acute angle
so vehicles coming out there can see
people from their path but the front or
their right a lot plus the front of the
building I believe there is a wall of
railings there is that the existing wall
of Rani's has been maintained or is that
being replaced and is that part of the
conditions of the development that that
fits there on the floor by that we had
there there are no street lights
mentioned on assuming that there will be
streetlights if I'd like to see that
with regards to the speed limit within
the development site I noticed that on a
couple of junctions there there was
raised platforms particularly on the of
the spine right there
it currently enough that development
over a bracelet that has now come
forward that that's going to have a
twenty mile an hour speed limit impose
right throughout the development that's
just coming forward from County I would
like to see the same prior to this
because there will be people going in
there and out there particularly
weekends children playing on the
football pitches parents walking down
there is representing the our concern I
have is with regards the buildings in
picture there to the left of the picture
there's a number of balconies there
dislike the balconies themselves but I'm
very concerned about the over parking
but at the overview II of the properties
obviously we don't have any indication
there is how close they are the lower
balconies I don't think will be crossed
from but something the second-floor ones
will have quite a few of the properties
obviously and I think that may be of
concern to the residents there so
there's a number of conditions there I'd
like to see adding to the conditions and
if necessary I'm quite happy to arrange
that as members of the project
councillor missus or what
you
mr. Hawley
thank you so it's different
also the patient is totally utilizing to
with regards to talking emotionally the
application under C 2 so the parking
spaces are as I'll make you there
seventeen three communiques and we are
saying there are three muses it's one
parking space for every three faiths I
seem to remember so extra to walk way
through Joshua the twenty five spaces so
we've provided Twitter five spaces for
visitors and three spaces for fall 2015
and that is there a notice basis for any
residents in situ as they normally
described before we will expect many if
any presidents that have a vehicle
this however is assisted living and
assisted living isn't mentioned by name
under c2 classification even under car
parking arrangements on of our residents
of this assisted living banned from
having cars that's the period on just
further
the Swedes five to three does agree to
accede to and he does agree to a six a
voluntary classic way that was used to
do that's the new
suppose
would be any traffic calming measures
puts in place on the spiders
and the agent also mentioned about
sustainable buildings
you know they're talking about Carlson
happen all the blacks were seeing
electric vehicle charging Thank You
Jenny
manse what find any more questions sorry
because of as I said I'll be excited
patient roster page I was looking for
the additional points are deep means
maple neck which I can't find the page
up here moment is that spaces are going
to be slightly under the design guide
size or spaces and it was Sabin on
California reported this moment I'm
impatient austere that that's exactly
what I prefer classification of the how
the spaces are for visitors and for
staff I can't see why that's a Russian
help in reducing the cotton space sizes
there any other questions remembers
learn it was conscious at times going on
so we've got questions with regards to
wall high parking standards bins the
roads of twenty four twenty mile an hour
drop curves disability up ethics access
site construction conditions the
doctor'll standards of the road c23 ste
questions at the parking parking
standards so there we go
ancestors ways
what serves a time instant if in terms
of packing standards its sack sites in
yet so incidents of the
laughing silence is really addressed in
on the 33.1 between pointless room so
it's clarified that filling
dwelling-houses will try to come back
its basis which complies with the
standards and 3.2 infinite living it's
representative a should do not appoint
apply to a chiropractor's basis
community due to specific leadership as
residential ec2 as opposed to seeing
three esteem sufficient so in terms of
why would say inspector that arrangement
is if that originally was needs to be a
shortfall for the the design SSO design
and for highways in design and
commentary in terms of that provision
was not adequate so in terms of
verifying the position of the opposite
supports the non objection of Osaka
Castle siege which which do look upon us
Inflation they're not projected so from
that you can deduce that actually there
isn't a policy that in terms of the I
didn't quite get the point family
disability on a tree obviously it's been
designed to comply with bad design
manual thought from all scientists the
you know the setback visibility from the
sense of access points to enforce a fact
that we we behind the notional if you're
coming out in your path roughly or your
own line your eye line would be
obviously looking in his direction can't
see anybody
okay you just updated got a copy which
Simon Zoey
oh the sorbet the kids are in orbits but
I like the chair I don't quite see the
point you make about I always go back to
the chair
sorry the bin storage the site layout
plan doesn't actually show a big
collection area
agent Lee's correct me if I'm wrong but
it says you know they'll be stunned that
not the difference a nice taper that
will be standard provision at a cost of
under 65 per bin and there'll be you
know the bills would be taken out that
all voltage you will note from the
footages along watch way that there is
an entranceway that has a white metal to
accommodate in wagons about nature so
sort of big collection areas we don't
consider in issue the little water on
the right cleaning in not accountable
yeah in terms you mentioned understand
you mentioned parking you you mentioned
was supposed to pack on the road on
these state on the spinal cord
last question okay
yes so I asked the question that what
would be the implication so go there
okay
oh all I can say to that is you know one
can't account for human nature you know
it will happen but you know in terms of
planning cannot account for
eventualities accident we all the
answers are that really that the roars
is a standard it starts with a Bob that
will standard so but I accept the point
that you're making and in fact the other
nature was come so Williams mentioned
walk with respect infrastructure so with
this application I think the main points
that were raised were in terms of
vehicles affecting integrity of the road
surface in connection with construction
in pleased with that I think a lot of
the members take a view on it but in
terms of impacts we haven't been asked
to bond we've been approached by players
in terms of any commuted son's in lieu
of a mitigation works and respect the
highway infrastructure there what's the
point of sourcing back in relation to
the Act accessibility services again as
part of the process one would expect
that that highways would have commented
in terms of considering how many proper
curves that isn't something that they
comment on at least I'm not saying stop
points and a little design as well have
raised more concerns if for example with
with permeability of sites you know in
terms of how people move from one place
to the other to services that is
intrinsic about all the design process
and the authority of anticipated versus
a design in particular would have
mentioned back if it was another concern
I think any infrastructure improvements
live here is it would need to be
proportional so there may be a valid
point that you're raising back and in
the discussion I think members should
look at report Mohammed II as the as the
sort of the guiding principle moving
onto the lens
I think the simulations we sit down in a
procession without the civility essence
with that that point is taken humble
perspective it's about the site in terms
of the final conditions Essex and saw
the leave obligations and then saying
that so members not to consider whether
given that legal safe and whether the
application of condition will be
necessary to safeguard because it's
actually they have to be provided as an
actor I believe that woman's in any case
so I'm not sure whether there would be a
need of look at the planning condition
in the Planning Commission is someone
would be aligned it would achieve that
in any case so all evening is there
could be more mass there was the closest
that I mentioned the wheel wash so I
think that
it would be in order for the local
authority to ask for construction
management plan to basically ascertain
and agree all phases of development that
should be in addition obviously when
we're doing construction stage is going
to be a lot of comings and goings is
going to be potential thus and this is
these kind of safe as in terms of how
construction on site may affect amenity
of residents in the area in many
respects in terms of movements of
vehicles at creating hours of building I
think even its it's residential Saturday
it would be more important to formulate
purposeful concise planning conditions
that sets out operating hours movements
of more resources five o'clock in the
morning one would not expect anything
where there's a sign so I think that
might be covered by condition but it
would be more in the provision and
agreements in accordance with a
construction management plan the road
repairs and condition and other paths
you mentioned potentially intersection
of six agreements I think that's all
things are discussed and we have got to
be more back but it'll actually be
sexual assisted means so just like with
a trade like that the Canadian site the
existing wall to replace
that's was it the wine state makes very
clear that the warden readings which is
over sort of a practice if you show the
footage is actually going to be retained
as fact the developments sweet lights
good point breeze and here think sweet
biting and I'm assuming that's a lot
that will fly anyway so in terms of the
only thing there is in terms of a
lighting plan that requires
specifications of luminosity of the
lights and things so that be something
that could be commissioned quite the
first installation that than prior to
commencement you know as long as that is
the property is not a role in in
facilitating development but providing
the certainty about certain parameters
before that she implements that part of
the scheme the issue about please
overlook came at the front it locks onto
the street and the minimum separation
distances 25 meters are achieved at the
skin so it was looking into it more as a
result back garden it would be a very
valid concern regarding overlooking this
is looking on to the fact that p1 is a
is that as a public domain and the
policy of c2 and c3 news is really in
the report basically the independently
living accommodation and Tom's views
that's the best in your points the
provision of independent living doesn't
actually fulfill at dwelling-house poly
fuse classes all under it doesn't all
that criteria it is in the altercation
ready by engines in points Watson from
the event women's and it's also covered
in 113 that the report and it says 13
2016 7 point 9 please he gives us at all
the sets of different acts abusive
residential use and makes a distinction
between residential institutions class
need to underground houses Class III
there was considerable case for coming
he'll end the courts on the definition
of both there is no guidance on which
use class order extra pair housing falls
into the decisions we made and the
individual services of the case but the
in conjunction with frozen officer
things have moved on in in the in in
Samoa consideration of this matter
because you will remember initially
linked to the affordable housing
information yeah
it's something that wasn't 41.6 of all
homes in the Liberty phase to something
of that nature and it was Essex roses
interpretation the use of classes or
everything else about leaded to that so
that sort of submarine but looking at
the use of passes on and looking at the
planning policy that that we have before
us the it's clear up see that this
development of holdings of the to the
case is that what it does not fall
within the definition of c3 and the
implication of fact is it it's it's I
think it's opposed to H all I think
disease but requires affordable housing
in it but it doesn't take them out the
requirements and given then the
remaining sight of them do not point
finding there's covered in the report
somewhere neither does not trigger the
requirement for affordable housing the
agents is covered in the report the
agent has indicated that this two phases
if you like those sites but the phase
one development they expect about to
face warned about as cousins some of
this hasn't been purposely minimized to
to a site town it all the required
varies triggering point that reasonable
OC so in fact I think it's point
thirteen point six pace and quite a nine
that answers your question
section C 2 and C 3 and then the was the
spine hold traffic calming measures and
broad again in terms of that they're all
doesn't show the presenting sort of way
they use the small traffic down but back
that's I'll leave that's the step
conditions they might be some things we
immediately might mean something
together
I'd like to strengthen condition ten by
including disability Essex so there is
no arms at the end of the day I do these
and at time just welcome Kate and it was
just
House members will see at the
recommendation reporting path me that
hits
the imposition of a condition doubling
up with illegal agreement against the
government would say have it illegal to
have it in addition our varsity cell
system n-tuples
agreements so the agreement meant that
we might improve upon that partner
recommendation would secure the access
through the scientific disability assets
that were safety around commission
attention although we're referring to
things like we're referring to it the
STDs actually trusting us now understand
some I just don't really know well just
so I take on board what the officer is
saying okay okay next one with regards
to will wash the eventual plan would
like to see that condition and ease to
them could be the committee is another
way to approve this numbers construction
management plan added with regards to
the paths when 106 agreement just to
perhaps take their for a little bit
because it's difficult for us to put a
figure on that or say exactly what we
need can I suggest that a whatever six
bring the putting price to for the water
counselors working in conjunction with
officers and the developers to look at
the footpaths and agreeable what
improvements need to be made in terms of
making it more
and friendly button friendly I think we
might have a problem with that because
none of the Statue of the Consul tees
have made any requests in such an area
particularly Essex highways we're going
outside the area of the application and
the section 106 is broad a big item for
us to simply stick on as a condition I
don't think that that would be
appropriate at this time I'll just take
some professional time experimenting
it's a matter of functionality I think
members are suggesting that the distance
between the sights and the town center
would be reviewing about the crossing
for the weights the full points but you
have to come to hear that the impact of
the
we'll wait the town center but it's
disproportionate request based on on
this scale you have to be careful
this was challenged that a government
inspector might say I've got a shopping
list in my to improve the parts of the
network and in this case to fix that
problem it might be that the app could
be agreeable to make their contribution
selection works as part of a scheme
perhaps that Menace was pushed forward
to the highway policy but then we'd have
to consider if that grief that how long
that money should help
it's what our scheme really serve I
produced and incremented so I'm more
comfortable with a proportionality like
that rather than we asked in the
applicants who requested items all the
way for the town centre I said sentiment
photographer I have to advise you that
it should be proportional to the harm
generated by being by the scale I'm not
sure that a scheme of this magnitude
justifies being worse
Jeff I take on board the office what the
obsessed I was assuming that 106
wouldn't be in full payment for
completely rebuilding that whole path by
the way to the rush weights at the town
center I was assuming that that would be
a contribution but I'm afraid for me
this is quite a deal breaker within the
home scenario because it is a very
important part so I would like to see
something in the front water I hope you
down has been covered I think that's
going to be butane streetlights I
believe that that was covered as well
speed limits I would like to see that
pudding as a condition with some traffic
calming that we goes with this 20 mile
an hour speed limit I'm not sure exactly
what that would be whether that be
cushions humps or again the 20 mile an
hour speed that makes its down to Essex
take some Singh advice here
I'm not familiar with the braised line
situations question that it's mention it
but I would imagine that because it's a
school access you remember when we dealt
with the application and committee
highways didn't request that management
department planning application now
there are issues with imposing speed
limiter to their safety ordinance et
cetera
highways again have not asked this
novice to take forward in the
application and I'm concerned sensitive
but we expect is saying that it's
required or justified through the
application making sure we're not take
on board what the officer is suggesting
but what I would say is that there we've
already agreed to football pictures
being used in the parking for that and
all the kids that will be using that so
understand why boy mr. Hoyer that's the
body
thank you Jevon the page which might
help disturbance is 7.24 and it's an
appointment trip from stars
understanding their talk is basically
greatest places pains I keep using it
later on
thanks some point for longer refers to
25 bases bus 338 there's no reference
data sparking sizes have a parking space
ice eventually simply or where they are
below the size is recommended paragraph
so that's we think was published as what
was quite decent length because that's
the minimum size required however if we
then go to 13 page 30 of the addendum
basics highway say the party shall be
Alden to eat we're as we promised
capitalize on their site and therefore
start spaces
just a new follow up now cutter cut more
then see what can we just flick back
through a three life that's really
totally we had a junction
get going
we love with the jump you email
that's it so that should ease travicom
as she goes up that's nicer to you
and it's just one of the carrot for that
year and also if I may I think the point
of the addendum is not over rights what
was previously been in the report so I
think counselor always absolutely right
no sorry should be you know as stated
but in accordance with which is great
thank you quiet person it's going to
come on to people they've got to
contribute
that's the Williams that's the whole
point and then we'll sum up
student media relaxer
I do agree with caps couple that that
looks like the eighties of Ray section
the Angels to that side
I'd like to condition that
that said to help in becoming on the
main spine road that it's a raised
platform which includes subscribers
that's a woman's
University security to
as
okay cancer staff Joe will get you've
got the two controversial items so
that's just taking one of your time
please
and see whether they get a part of the
record with the overall recommendation
or not so can you start with the mini
absolute precision here I'm going to
suggest in section 106 please Becky
check yes or the wall counselors to work
with officers and the developers to
determine what the path requires in
terms of repairs and improvements and a
contribution from the developers towards
the cost of date numbers you're happy
with that meant addition as a condition
yeah okay thank you
that's my level
let's check this with regards to the 20
mile an hour speed limit in particular
because of the access to the playing
fields a particular weekends there's
going to be a lot more traffic going
beyond it and to include with these 20
mile an hour speed limit the necessary
farming measures that would be required
on the spy drone the 20 mile an hour
speed limit quiet it's been suggested
that they could be either raised
platforms sometimes their cushions are
you happy with that beer and there's a
condition cancer Mountain education we
can you make no condition if it's not
good unless it's always stated is it
well it's you know a conditional to be a
recommendation
agent further consultation with Essex
County highways regarding our desire for
insist on being
the specification ultimately the rope
and this council
problem sweetie
so grants commission subject to that
defense that the applicant may choose to
agree with you
to them might take a different view but
it's unnecessary and over a reasonable
and then challenge that through an
appeal and that sound concern for the
defenseman with have a support so
extensions from the County Fire
Authority said we would be alone on
today and we have the expertise to
justify but its members to make that
call that's why we're saying that the
same the county highway project looked
is the only acceptable my weight
Brandon's we're debating the idea
further spec into into the highway that
they don't seek that's our knowledge
snap down taken forward for consultation
but still wanted to push that forward
by members as I've seen it at the moment
we have on the addendum the
recommendation that points us to page
7.50
20 heads of condition with number 16
being removed we have the additional
words that are printed on page 15 of the
addendum to have an additional condition
about the construction and management
lab we have an additional condition
regarding the ward councillors working
with the developers contribution towards
some highway improvements on the roofs
towards the town centre and we have a
form of words to be clarified with the
officers with regard to the
specification about controlling speed
within the spine Road of the site that's
a fair summary so that members based on
all of that we have the recommendation
for approval those members in favor
please
thank you very much for a very thorough
discussion of that item sorry for
yesterday
and now move on to what file item item
eight perch Lodge ankle Lane kanuda I've
really come for break but members five
minutes
yeah
[Music]
let's teleport immediately
[Music]
very top intervention there yeah it
would have been problem - yeah skis
not the best one it's flickering to get
the matter look at the nothing
is tougher than my show to sing
alright you get started here members
please
okay
unfortunately a couple of minor three
members have to play for the equipment's
over on the yeah okay so and I like my
mate
much like ankle a decent housing be on
dear st. Nicholas Church
this is a huge feature system iconic
seriously possible
the point four five hectare site is part
of the wider world woodpecker person
okay
the young patient is a turtle
maybe this neighbor called an
application with a 380 scientists
adjacent told some major application mr.
Jang
it's like induced by cuttings which [ __ ]
as a reminder this is the January 2007
application
this proposal is a total of fortunate
runnings to make a fermented national
artisan nitration two properties would
be to touch play to the footage access
onto the remaining properties would be
accessed through the adjacent Vieques
200 site postponement has been
influenced by the spirits from site
adjacent Matata Kiva village / the
two-story majors such as remote official
tradition and setting of the church
policy page 5 requires needs bug -
potato mix of grain sacks to assure the
case of political and community
development Lucas's permission raise two
to six pages of science particularly
slow case one sitting outside with
detached houses and five bedrooms in one
of the houses and six veterans in the
other when one gazes on the ground floor
these would be access Michael a hang
these on plus three importantly
penicillin touched noses remained of the
place and secondly to positive us houses
thoughts about tonight would be a great
lesson rest we made applause 2014 would
give a block facing south as you can see
from the elevation plans
misuk Malaysia process evaluation
greenforest in the positive materials
pretty negative items of skin all voids
of the budget private community areas it
succinctly in sunder national space once
at least one dose in that parking is
integrated within building toss you can
use a small parking lot lastly under
supports its occupation or 32 you'll be
total critics parking spaces the two
spaces for each train services spaces
justice in accordance with the standards
the two delays at the phone without each
other
total to post dated outside and until
2004 third space and also business the
houses derivative test plans with their
relative sizes each I know mr. pocket
Tony's a scientist offsets from existing
buildings and the first place on the
Phoenix site to avoid directly to his
attention thousand units so two parking
areas and this time we'll be going
upstairs
the positive these houses opposite areas
someone said manaslu suspect an existing
project obstructed with ability to
planners from the first race on the
basis of this no officers Tanaka said oh
they will be directed we're looking
represent furthermore our separation
distances as well as policy are
satisfied policy haste boy requires at
least 35 cents 24:52 were used to be
affordable food although the proposal is
14 points in the spirit of threshold the
most part of the wider STR 7 allocation
and the quanta source of sorts the
problem is on this site five plays were
provided
such as a ton of the patients with input
someone with a master's completing
post-discharge piloted by the existing
participation at least surface water
that we discussed my new conversation in
society
system where possible depending on
material assets is provided to strength
nice
there's also titled 75 20 minutes of
attenuation measures
it is considered that primarily
successful including on citizen
computation postponed into the ninth I
cater to the cessation programs officer
specific titles in the course of
personal requirements first of all you
would come to making clear to Jason for
making science recommendations therefore
for approval suggested issue
thank you I don't know what the
councilors policy of parking spaces for
premises as there are five and six
bedrooms properties could you tell me
how many parking spaces are in policy of
cultural district council and how many
are actually allocated please for any
other members wishing to make a comment
just do that reference of marking
senator centers the larger properties
just say that five or six penalties and
protocol to the marriage of two spaces
musician to the couch as well and also
mr. Marcus fiesel must've taken three
spaces
Chairman I think it's in the report
I've read it pretty right but the
requirement is for one 1320 to have one
space two bedroom two aliens you have
the two spaces also more than two
bedrooms has two spaces and also for
service place of visitors report riots
and Bob's checking but I think remembers
there's a recommendation printed on page
eight and three one going treat from
three to remove the recommendation for
for both numbers and pay but approval
please indicate is carried that case it
concludes the more thank you very much
he blows that
you
you